hey youtubers is Charlie so comic-con is
this week naturally there's a whole
bunch of comic book TV show movie news
dropping so the latest rumor is is
there's some very big characters from
the Batman universe coming to Supergirl
season 2 so I'm gonna start with like
the most likely rumors going down to
least likely the biggest rumor right now
is that both Cathy Kane who you guys
will know as Batwoman and Barbara Gordon
as Oracle will both guest star on
Supergirl season 2 the idea of Batman
family on that like the CW DC TV shows
is huge because previously I'd always
thought that they were exclusive to
Gotham because of their deal with Warner
Brothers but turns out that's like way
more complicated than I ever thought it
involves this DVD release the classic
Batman series that Fox has the rights to
so it sounds like any version of the
Batman character himself is exclusive to
Gotham if they ever get to that point
I'm sure there's like some special deal
behind that too because right now he's a
little kid but it does not include every
single member of the Batman family so I
know everybody's like still hoping for
Nightwing on arrow I'm sure that that's
like still somewhere floating off in the
distance if there's a Teen Titans show
that's never gonna happen but the idea
behind Batwoman and Oracle on Supergirl
would be that they build a birds-of-prey
just with Supergirl instead of Black
Canary because they like the closest
thing that we have to Black Canary
in the CW universe right now is black
siren she's on earth too she's still a
villain so she'll come back but I'm only
expecting Katie Cassidy to guest star
maybe like once this season so you know
future seasons to be determined
obviously the follow-up or people are
like well hey if they're doing Batman
family characters does that mean that
Batman exists in this universe well they
already had like the arrow Easter Egg
where they were giving Felicity a
codename and ended up being overwatch
Oliver made the joke that it was going
to be Oracle but that name was already
taken meaning that there is a Barbara
Gordon Oracle inside the arrow flash
universe on earth 1 now Supergirl is on
a different earths Alisa a completely
different circumstance but because
they're doing Superman they're doing
Batwoman so doing Oracle yes of course
Batman exists on that earth but my
expectations for them talking about
Batman Bruce Wayne specifically or
relatively low like I will be totally
satisfied if they only make like
single offhanded reference to someone
that sounds like Bruce Wayne like they
don't have to say his name is totally
cold like you kind of understand that
Batman is so complicated when it comes
to TV rights and movies that you're just
like oh my god I'm still so happy to be
getting half of the Batman family so you
know Batwoman Oracle is really like the
biggest deal that woman is big but
Oracle is even bigger you can kind of
see the idea with characters jumping
around like you may have heard about
Captain colds deal Wentworth Miller
signed a deal with Warner Brothers
television to be a series regular on all
of their DC TV shows and when you hear
things like that you're thinking mostly
about story like oh you know how is that
gonna work what's the continuity of his
character between all four shows or is
it gonna be a multiverse thing like
you're thinking more about the logic but
really it from a practical perspective
it's a way for the TV shows to use them
and if they're too expensive like
Wentworth Miller is a little bit more
expensive and in terms of like the guest
stars that they use so when he becomes a
series regular on all four shows they
just allows them to spread the cost of
their deal across the budgets of all
four shows so it's just some fancy
footwork from behind the scenes that
gets like the producers finding a
cheaper way to bring characters on the
show but in doing so they have to share
the cost across all four shows it's just
it makes it easier from the Duke really
big characters that they normally
wouldn't be able to afford on one single
show so also very plausible but
unconfirmed is the idea that Jay Garrick
would be the next character to get a
deal like this now I'll talk more about
this from a story perspective like you
know what would the story be if Jay
Garrick were to guest starring all four
TV shows in like a separate flash video
but just in the simplest of terms think
about just a society on legends of
tomorrow this season Jay Garrick if you
if you wonder like what big story Jay
Garrick was a part of on Justice Society
the short answer is every single Justice
Society story he's a founding member of
the Justice Society so if you're gonna
do them you might as well do a version
of Jay Garrick but if you're thinking
that like all this news of you know
doing like a broader DC universe just
spread out over four different shows
like a true big comic book crossover
event and you're like how come they
haven't done this before this is some
high level deal making going on
behind the scenes and I think from
behind the scenes from a studio
perspective they're just like very
cautious
doing big things like this when they
haven't been proven so it's almost like
flash arrow legends of tomorrow kind of
have to prove their worth like look at
the things that we did now can we do the
next thing you know can we do this big
broader thing that they were trying to
do this big crossover I think so the
studio is like sees how successful they
are and they're like okay you can try
this new weird thing this new weird deal
you know sharing your deal across for TV
shows so that's why you probably haven't
heard about something like this
happening before it's also a really easy
way to use the Constantine character now
there's a rumor about Constantine being
like a new TV show on the CW and I put
that rumor and like very unlikely the
latest rumor just says that the CW you
know they license all the Constantine
season 1 episodes from NBC so a lot of
people were like hey what does this mean
well it really just means that they're
looking for cheap content that's also in
the DC TV universe but there's a rumor
that says that they're using that as a
test to see how interested people are in
the Constantine character like hey you
know if people really like the fact that
we license these episodes maybe we
should make some more of them so while
it is somewhat unlikely that they would
start a new Constantine TV show for like
you know like Friday night so they had 5
nights of DC TV instead of just four
nights but really what I'd like to see
is if they're gonna do Constantine is
just to share him across all four TV
shows like they would do with Jay
Garrick or the Batman family you know
just allow him to cross over with all
four t v-- shows every once in awhile so
really like the big takeaway news from
this like the you know most likely would
be a version of birds of prey on
Supergirl which would definitely make
people want to watch a bar I would
definitely be more interested in
Supergirl if they were doing birds of
prey Batman characters and then Jay
Garrick just to society you know
crossing over with the other DC shows so
let me know what you guys think about
the idea of bat woman and Oracle on
Supergirl for birds of prey and then Jay
Garrick gets starring in a Justice
Society arc on legends of tomorrow if
you weren't sure they are going to be
dropping trailers for the new seasons of
all the DC TV shows this week so I'll be
doing videos for each of those but those
won't start dropping to like Friday and
Saturday so be sure to subscribe to get
that stuff so there is a new round of
the giveaway that starts now there'll be
DC Marvel Game of Thrones all kind of
giveaways happening this week so I'll
remind everyone when I post videos but
all you have to do to enter the DC
giveaway is just be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video I'll be
doing a flash video that'll talk a
little bit more about Jay Garrick going
on the other TV shows especially
comic-con stuff that's gonna be
happening specific to the flash this
week so that'll probably post tomorrow I
still want to do a Star Wars Episode 8
video so that'll probably be my next
video while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for my
Game of Thrones Comic Con preview and
you can click here for my Wonder Woman
Comic Con preview thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight